[Music]
hi my name is Danielle tersk and I am a
professor of chemical and biological
engineering at Northwestern University
where I also co-direct the center for
synthetic biology and today I'm going to
talk about engineering a complex
phenotype how we've used High throughput
approaches to develop a new protein
biomanufacturing
platform so the motivation for our work
is that recombinant proteins are a large
and important Market um whether you're
talking about therapeutic proteins
industrial enzymes protein materials or
other markets that aren't listed
here and to make all of these proteins
we can achieve really high tighter
production in
bacteria H that gives us a really high
quantity the bacteria are easy to
manipulate they grow really quickly
they're not very expensive to
grow but unfortunately the lab strains
do not secrete functional non-native
proteins efficiently and so they are low
quality and so often you will find that
those industries that I just mentioned
will turn to other production hosts
instead of bacteria to make their
products so we see this as primarily a
failure in um purification when you are
making protein in bacteria you are
necessarily going to have to deal with
separating out your protein of interest
from all of the other proteins that the
cells are making um intracellularly or
in some of the organisms that do have
some robust secretion they also secrete
a lot of their own proteins in a way
that we cannot completely
eliminate
and so the goal when we started out on
this project in my lab was to optimize
protein production in bacteria for both
quantity and
quality and specifically we were aiming
to produce over a gram per liter of
protein um so a gram of protein per
liter of cells that we are growing with
over 90% Purity without doing any
additional purification steps and also
more than 90% of those should be
functional or Ive in other words
properly folded so we want to do this
again without those Downstream
purification steps and so taking
advantage of a secretion system within
the bacteria
itself and we set these goals in part
because we had been working with a
system from salmonella Anda a um
particular craar from a mouse infecting
strain known as typh
Marium and it has this set of type three
secretions systems one of which is
pretty well characterized that had the
potential to meet those tighter Purity
and cost objectives that I just
mentioned for rec combinant protein
production in bacteria and so these
systems are really interesting they are
um pretty large operons so something
like on the order of um 23 to 25
proteins involved in making the
structure itself as um structural
proteins are involved with that process
and you can see it looks a lot like a um
a needle and syringe where the syringe
is the green and pink part and the
needle is that basil body that's sitting
across the two membranes as well as the
periplasm of the salmonella which is a
gram negative
bacteria and so the polypeptide actually
uh comes from the cytoplasm and is
secreted in one step all the way out of
these
cells so we had been working with the
system for some time in a variety of
ways from um the 2008 or n time frame
and we had already seen that we could
use known uh secretion tags these are
sequences protein sequences or amino
acid sequences that go at the end
Terminus of the protein of interest that
you would want to secrete so you can
encode this
genetically and when you attach these
secretion tags that are from natively
secreted proteins onto whatever you want
to secrete
we found that we could secrete a diverse
set of proteins of interest um this was
started in this work shown from
2009 and continued in my lab in some
unpublished work we actually tested
about 80 different proteins that
bacteria make none of which are
necessarily secreted natively and about
80% of those 80 proteins were compatible
with the secretion
system and these the system already um
was known to be able to secrete protein
but the tighter is the really important
part and so with some initial work that
we did in the 2010s early 200 um TS we
were able to show that we could
manipulate a little bit about the
regulation of the system to get it to be
active in all of the cells in the
population and not just some as it was
natively and we were able to achieve
over a 100 migs per liter for many of
the proteins that we tested uh this is
great it's not quite the gram per liter
that we were going for and um what I'll
describe in the rest of this talk and
then one other thing that we knew by
around 2015 is that those proteins that
we were secreting actually were folding
correctly and were fairly High Purity
around
80% um with some of the other proteins
that were still being secreted in from
the Native system at that time and um
the correctly folded proteins included
alkine phosphatase and uh antibody
fragments which do have disulfide bonds
so even though we didn't have any
chaperon in the media uh they were able
to fold properly and so that was really
exciting and that's what L us to really
began wondering how far could we push
this system and could it be used uh for
commercializable
applications um we were inspired but we
knew we had a lot of work ahead of us
and so on this slide I'm showing that we
need to do several things from that
point to actually reach a commercial
relevance with this system so the first
is uh engineering the regulation of the
system to control it we're in a unique
position with the system in salmonella
that it's not always present and that's
great but uh also it has a very
complicated Network controlling its
production and the presence or absence
of the apparatus itself
is dependent on integrating a lot of
signals and so we need to overcome this
regulatory control and we did a little
bit of that work early on we found this
master regulator Hill a that by um
putting this on a plasmid and
artificially expressing this master
regulator we are able to induce the
system but that's not the ideal method
for industrial applications we don't
want to use expensive inducers and we
really wanted to avoid extra plasmids in
the system as well
and so finding ways to control that was
high on our list we also wanted to make
the secretion process more efficient we
were getting over 100 migs of protein
per liter but we were leaving quite a
substantial amount of protein still
behind in the cells unsecret at the time
points that we use and so anywhere from
uh 10 to 80% depending on the protein
and um of course this was without
optimization but we wanted to see what
controls that efficiency and then
finally we needed to increase the
tighter to that one gram per liter Mark
that we had uh decided was a good
Benchmark for pursuing further if we
could reach
it so here's the thing about these goals
as you may have surmised from the way I
was talking about it just now these were
not easy phenotypes to engineer it
requires extensive genomic changes
regulatory Cascade changes and the
phenotype in all cases is really how
much protein is is outside of the cell
at the end and we knew that for each
goal here success would likely require
screening thousands to millions billions
trillions um all the way up to maybe 10
to the 12 variations basically as many
variations as we could make uh in a test
tube at the DNA level or genome
level and so when you compare that goal
and the set of constraints that we uh
predicted that we would have in
achieving that goal uh and then you
compare that to what the gold standard
is for assing secretion as a phenotype
which is Western blooding there's quite
an incompatibility and so I want to back
up a second here and just talk about
what western blooding process looks like
and so here I show um we have our signal
peptide that's the secretion sequence
tag that's at the end Terminus of
whichever protein that we would want to
secrete and we have a detection tag in
purple at the very end of the um the
protein of Interest once it's uh
produced off of this plasma that I'm
showing and that detection tag is
anything that you can detect with
Western blooding so if there's an
antibody against it that will work and
then we also have the chapon shown in
red that's just to facilitate the
secretion process and it actually
interacts with the signal peptide so is
not um as important but is important to
represent here in the cartoon so if we
encode this this uh cassette this
expression cassette on a plasmid we will
make our polypeptide with its signal
sequence and its detection tag and we'll
make the chaperon which will help um by
binding to the secretion tag and guiding
it to the
needle or the um secretion apparatus in
the meantime if we were to take the
cells and um centrifuge them down so we
have the pellet of just cells and look
at what protein is present in that
we would see how much protein is being
produced by doing Western blood against
the cells once we activate this
secretion system and and have it
present um we would then be able to
detect whether or not it's going out so
if we don't have the secretion system in
place or for some reason the protein is
not being secreted because one of these
pieces is not working properly such as
the shaer at the signal peptide or the
apparatus itself if we do a western
Blood on the S the supernatant so the
media from doing that centrifugation
step where you remove the cells then you
wouldn't see a band on your Western blot
um but if you are able to secrete the
protein successfully through the
apparatus everything is going as planned
then you will see by uh assaying that
supern and assing the spent media if you
will you will see a band once again um
indicating that the protein was secreted
and so we can compare those if we're
very careful about quantification or we
can compare how much is secreted versus
what was in the entire culture so um
supernant and pellet alike combined
without separating the two and so that's
the gold standard um that is not going
to allow us to look at thousands or
hundreds of thousands of samples quickly
um you can look at something like 10 to
15 lanes per gel maybe if you have a
larger gel setup you can do more but
we're not talking about hundreds we're
still uh on the order of tens and so we
need new approaches for assessing
secretion tighter now fortunately
protein based assays abound and some can
and have been adapted for secreted
product and I want to focus on those
today so this slide shows three very
commonly used protein assays in the
protein engineering field in a lot of
fields even if not trying to engineer
the protein the first is enzyme activity
and so an example Le would be alkaline
phosphatase which is an enzyme that
Cleaves phosphate groups off of small
molecules and can be tied to the
appearance or disappearance of a color
based on which small molecule you've
introduced with a phosphate maybe you
cleave the phosphate and it leads to
disappearance of color you cleave the
phosphate and color appears because of
the product that uh remains after you
take the phosphate off now this uh assay
is dependent on the enzyme being
properly folded and is often a
multi-step assay to carry out but can be
done in microtiter well plates which
substantially increases the throughput
over a western blot and it does have
tunable dynamic range depending on how
much protein you have present the second
one is a growth assay this is where um
really comes in handy for something like
secretion so if you have the presence of
the protein there it usually leads to
growth although it could prevent growth
similarly to the enzymes um so if you
secrete a toxic enzyme you're enabling
growth because the toxic enzyme isn't
there um or maybe you need an
extracellular component to be present
and as long as that extracellular
component is present and you have your
protein of Interest present then you get
growth on that particular media um
potential for really high throughput but
a really small dynamic range and really
hard to tune these assays and then
finally we have Optical assays and
examples of those would be fluorescence
or luminescence if you were to use gfp
green fluorescent protein as a reporter
or a luciferase based product that
produces
luminescence and so these you're almost
always looking for appearance of signal
when you have the presence of this
reporter Protein that's Optical in some
way and it again depends on folding I
think in all cases that can be true and
but Optical assays do have an advantage
in that they're usually one step and so
a little bit simpler and again that
leads to medium throughput because you
can do it in micro tighter plates um but
you do get that large dynamic range back
even though you're at medium throughput
okay so I'm GNA talk for a moment about
what we've done with developing an assay
based on enzyme activity so this was
some earlier work where we wanted to
engineer the type3 needle complex itself
that's the complex shown in
green and
it's all made up of a single protein
that multimerizes to form an anulus so a
hollow cylinder as shown here um but it
really does come all from a single
monomer of alpha helical
structure and we knew that it was
potentially important it was implicated
in other systems that were homologous to
our type 3 secretion system as being
important for the amount of um activity
of those secretion systems and so we
introduced
mutations uh in every single position of
the gene encoding this needle protein
it's called prgi so we introduced
instead of just doing an alanine scan
where we introduce alanine at each
position we introduced each of the 20
amino acids using degenerate codons nnk
at each position and so the library size
here is we're looking at um the length
of the prgi protein in amino acids times
20 and that's how many we are screening
and so that is medium throughput because
prgi is not the largest Gene it's on the
order of a 100 amino acids in length we
then inserted this onto the genome which
is represented very poorly here as uh
just a circular piece of
DNA and then we screened for secretion
via alkaline phosphatase which was
appended to a secretion tag so the
library here is in the protein that
makes up the apparatus rather than the
protein that we're secreting and then we
used microti assay for alkaline
phosphatase activity to assess
secretion so this library in general
yielded 40% of the variants were still
functional so we didn't actually
completely destroy the activity of the
apparatus in 40% of the library members
and all of these remember are just one
amino acid away from the wild type
sequence and we actually had quite a few
variants shown in green on this chart
that gave us secretion activ it that was
much higher than our previous best
variant that was taken by homology from
the literature and so this is a
frequency so it's a histogram so the
x-axis is really the only one that
matters and that's the relative
secretion tighter so closest to the
origin we don't get any secretion the
wild type is the next hump and then you
can see quite a few um variants do do
outperform the wild type
significantly so we could have looked at
just those High secretion variants and
we did and but we also decided to look
at all variants and take advantage of
some uh Next Generation sequencing
affordability that we have now and so we
sorted every single well um from every
plate so this is um we maintained the
plates that had the cells from the ones
that we did the essays on and we went
back and split those out into low medium
and high secretion pools and sequenced
each of those pools and this led to
something that we'd call a secretion
Fitness landscape where we're truly
looking at the performance of every
single point mutant in our library every
single Library member and whether it
fell in the low medium or high category
and um so that's shown by this heat map
that you see on the right and to orient
you the xaxis of this heat map is the
amino acids the Y AIS is um the number
for the residue so at the bottom closest
to the origin of the graph would be the
end terminal amino acid and as you go up
the y- Axis you move to the C Terminus
and then the color is pink if we didn't
uh associate it with a high secretion
phenotype and it's green if it did
exhibit High secretion and the amount of
green if it's medium uh secretion more
like wild type it's a a medium color of
the green or teal color and so it's too
small to see here which amino acids
correspond to um which or which
positions are really important but
hopefully you can see the trends
around um the first Alpha Helix of the
protein is in the end Terminus and you
can see a lot of light green on the
bottom half of this secretion Fitness
landscape whereas you see a lot more
pink on the top half but also a lot more
dark green showing that we get the
highest performance from mutations that
are in the C terminal helix but also a
lot more chance for making a mutation
that would completely kill the activity
for
secretion and so now I'm going to show a
video to show how that mapped on to the
actual structure of the needle and this
was fascinating to us because the heat
map itself maybe is very informative if
you spend a lot of time staring at it
but what was really striking is that
when we watch this video you will see
that we're going to be pretending to be
the polypeptide being secreted down the
barrel or the center of this cylinder um
going out through this secretion uh
apparatus and it's going to look a
little bit like a rifle barrel um with
that nice turn in it and there's some
grooves major and minor grooves and we
thought if anything we've probably
widened this tunnel with the mutations
we made in um those sea terminal does
face the interior so we thought we're
probably widening the tunnel when in
fact as you'll see in the video in a
second the green um that you're going to
see there is associated with mutating
small residues to be much larger and
bulkier residues so um here we will
watch the
video all right so we're um going down
oh I'm sorry I used the wrong color
coding on this um so here red is not
good and blue is the one that
is the the mutations that we were able
to make so I'm gonna um show it one more
time from the
beginning and so again you can see that
those blue residues that's where we're
mutating to fill in more of this
cylinder and it's it's pretty striking
that there's so much blue inside here
which corresponds to the green on the
previous
slide and so this has led to a lot of
new activ in my lab which I don't have
time to go into today um but I do want
to just take the last few minutes to
talk about another assay that we
developed to test all the hypotheses
that came from that uh really
interesting mapping of the heat map onto
the structure and um with that I'm going
to talk about an optical assay that we
developed so as I mentioned a
fluorescent reporter seems like a more
natural way to go and you might have
even been wondering why we used an
enzymatic reporter in the prior study
the answer is that yes it would be great
if we could secrete a fluorescent
protein and then just use an optical
property or even a luminescent protein
or one that confers luminescence um
you'd spin down the supernant and
collect collect it and look at the
fluoresence of
that um and directly detect your
fluoresence it's one step it would be
really easy fast easy and low eror very
quantitative unfortunately green
fluorescent protein and all its variants
are not compatible with our secretion
system this is often a problem with
secretion of green fluorescent protein
the chromophor prevents it from
unfolding for transport across the
membrin and so we found from work by
David Baker and his colleagues a
monomeric fluoresence activated protein
or mfap and thought it might be a
promising alternative to use for our
secretion
assays and so in this assay that we've
developed oops my animations are going
hang wire and we see see that we are
able to detect fluorescence when we add
substrate it does require adding
substrate to our media that contains
hopefully a secreted mfap
protein in if we have the secretion
system present we don't see any
fluoresence without the secretion system
present and we don't see any fluoresence
if we have the secretion system but not
that fluorescent activating fluence
activating
protein the secreted mfat protein
actually gives us signal that's linear
across three orders of magnitude so
tremendous dynamic range regardless of
the media that we use and that's what
this plot is showing and we were able to
use it to explore our and terminal
secretion tags in more detail and so I'm
just going to back up to talk a little
bit more I mentioned earlier there's a
chapon it turns out that the secretion
tag itself has a chapon binding domain
as well as a secretion signal to it and
we wanted to see what role each of those
pieces played in um conferring secretion
or secret ability to our proteins of
interest and so our goal for a model
secretion tag would be the highest
secretion tighter possible and the
highest secretion efficiency and we
thought these might be toggled
differently by the signal versus The
chapon Binding domain and chapon we also
wondered if there would be differences
observed with different proteins of
Interest so um there are quite a variety
of tags and chaperons to choose from
which we wanted to mix and match and
that leads to quite a combinatorial
challenge that we used our map assay to
address so the first thing we did was
make sure that our map assay using
fluoresence actually matched the gold
standard of the western blot and this
plot here is showing that testing each
of the secretion sequences found in
nature in its normal form um in Western
blotting as well as in the floresent
Sass gives us essentially the the same
results when
normalized um to the secretion tighter
of sptp which was the primary sequence
we had been using in the
past and um then we did that mixing and
matching uh with our mfat protein of all
the different secretion signals all the
different chapter and binding domains in
every order
possible um to give 42 different
experiments and we found indeed that we
could assay this with map and that
actually the very best one was a
combination that was not a natural
combination of chapon um binding domain
and Signal sequence so that was really
exciting that this particular A5
sequence is not one that's found in
nature and so then we thought okay let's
take this further because that took
about uh less than a week start to
finish to do that whole experiment on 42
um but that's not really stretching out
the Sass too far so we looked at all of
the other advances that we had made that
I described earlier in this talk methods
of increasing the secretion tighter
where we engineered the filament or
needle the
prgi um removing the tip complex with
some of our earlier work uh that I
alluded to earlier um changing the
regulation of the system um using the
hill a master regulator that I mentioned
earlier on a plasmid in in other ways
where manipulated The genome to control
the levels of Hilla using modifications
to other uh Hill proteins and then
finally we even made changes to the
media um testing a lot of different
media and isolating one in particular
that we thought was really the best by
far because of its ability to both lead
to high cell growth and expression of
our secretion system and so we combined
10 different strains two different
methods for expressing The Hil and two
different media in the end for testing
this um mfap aay and we were able to
show again a surprise that our very best
performing strain and plasmid and media
combination was actually one that
doesn't require any plasmid and takes
advantage of all of the changes that we
had made to the cell line itself and
that there were a couple of others that
really do have high fluorescence as well
indicating very high secretion tighter
um that you can see uh in the the far
right uh Lane of these heat maps and
where dark blue is how much protein is
secreted as measured by the map aay and
so we compared these results back to
Western blotting on just those key um
the key strain plasmid combinations and
so the one highlighted in red on the
heat map there is shown and the far
right on the bar graft um that's on the
left on here and so what we're seeing
now with all these improvements
additively is something on the order of
three to fourfold more tighter so we now
have tighters over 400 migs per liter
and we are able to do that once again in
basically less than a week all these
experiments so and we are able to do
dozens of experiments at a time with
mfat but we think we can extend this to
hundreds at a
time and then just to wrap up a little
bit on something that I said was
important to us early on we wanted to
show that this advances that we make
with the secretion system aren't just
going to apply to our reporter protein
so in this case the fluorescent reporter
or in the the prior example I gave the
enzyme reporter of alkal and phosphatase
and so here I'm showing that the results
are upheld we still get the two to
threefold improvements that we were
seeing when we use uh other reporter
proteins that are actually models of
human proteins that we might want to
produce in this way one is um human
intersec and the other one is human
growth hormone so that's the black and
the gray bars
respectively and so hopefully from this
I've um given you some information on
the various assays that you can use to
look at protein either expression
secretion or uh presence depending on
what you're trying to assay in my case
it was secretion so presence in the
supernatent was what we were looking for
um and also that protein secretion
Machinery are really amenable to
engineering via targeted Library methods
and what was lacking was these High
throughput screens and so we can use uh
fluoresence or enzyme assays to take the
place of Western blotting in the future
and I think this can extend not only um
to other studying type 3 secretion
systems in various bacteria but those
studying the secretion systems in any
organism um should be be able to apply
these same medium throughput methods
that far exceed the low throughput
Western blooding and they can be coupled
as we did with Comprehensive mutagenesis
and Next Generation sequencing
strategies and so I'm really excited
about that I want to thank with my few
seconds all the students um shown in
bold here that contributed to the work I
showed their pictures and so they will
know who they are but um Lisa berett
really spearheaded a lot of the early
work with Kevin metf and hang Wong on
this and more recently Sam leech and
Julie leang have done a lot of the later
work that I showed you and um in fact we
spun out a company Opera bioscience
which I am required to disclose that
uses the advances that we made in the
secretion system um all of this work was
funded by a variety of sources including
but not limited to the National Science
Foundation and um National Labs as well
as as Northwestern University uh my
contact information website and Twitter
handle are here if you would like to
reach out with any other questions I'm
also available by email or in the chat
thank
you